are you think aside from Esports are you
thinking of do you ever think you're
going to get into like any other
business or any other field well I mean
you're also what you did the comic right
yeah we're still working on it
absolutely insane I feel like you're
you're doing so many massive things all
at the same time yeah and it's like
crazy to see especially with the two
videos a day plus streaming it's like
you'd never think the guy who buys six
giant dildos is like a Saturday I'm just
trying to like a French chat you know
it's like it's it's awesome it's it's
inspiring honestly is this the lucky
position to be in to do those things
like yeah those are all dream things
like doing the comic book doing the
Esports organ stuff like that it's just
things I've always wanted to do so to be
able to do it is just I love doing it is
there like anything else you like really
want to like take off the bucket list
that you can say on camera
um you need to make a whole show yeah
that we definitely want to do that we've
been we've been working on our Netflix
pitch which will hopefully be coming up
sometimes oh hell yeah hell yeah uh do
you wanna do you want to explain your
comic book to to the fans yeah so God's
lab is something we started a few years
back so Matt Danny Jackson and I created
it it's just this really goofy like
cyberpunk-esque world where people are
slapping the [ __ ] out of each other
there's without giving too much away
there's there's some villains like the
Fister who they maybe use his his fist
as opposed to an open car
and basically it's the adventure of as
finding his place in that world right
now as well as eventually squaring off
with that guy that's the arc we're
currently on I think how did by the time
this comes out the second the animation
thing we'll have drawn hopefully so
right now the reason we've had issue two
done for a while but we've had a problem
with like paper shortages and everything
because everything's in a shortage so
it's a little out of our hands at the
moment but hopefully so how did the idea
come about
I think it was it wasn't right after
that either because Jackson was talking
about like some dumb Star Wars [ __ ]
because he's a big Star Wars fan I was
like Jackson's is stupid you know what
would be cool slapping and then I we
just started talking about slapping and
this was right after like the biggest
one I think it was Vasily versus a Lesh
right that was massive yeah like I
remember when you covered the slapping
videos I would just see a video we have
10 million views oh it was such it's
such a fun sport I was like what the
[ __ ] is this it's the most eastern
European sport I've ever seen because
it's like I feel like Eastern Europeans
are not happy unless someone is near
diet yep no it's like I was surprised
there wasn't like glassing incidents of
like slamming their head on like an
actual pint or something crazy it was it
went hard so when is one of them getting
sponsored by moisty Sports
someone's gonna die from that slapping
someone did die no really yeah and it's
actually one of the biggest guys in the
scene his name was valus uh Artur values
wait what happened you got slapped die
so the champion zalesh slapped him so
hard that he lost Consciousness briefly
but he came to his brain started
hemorrhaging they had to rush him out
and he was put into a medically induced
coma and he didn't make it holy [ __ ] oh
my God if you if you look at the guy
though you would never expect someone
like him could even be pierced by a
bullet like he was one of the biggest
men I've ever seen I'm guessing they
didn't like halt the Esports at all the
time no I'm pretty sure they actually
had to stop okay that Division I think
had to stop because I haven't seen them
do anything like that since that was
their big like big tournament that that
happened it'd be pretty bizarre it
seemed kind of like a less lesser of an
organized sport more of a we have this
big guy who wants to try and slap him he
is currently the champion yeah yeah it
was very much these are [ __ ] freaks
and they're gonna slap each other yeah
it definitely seemed like kind of like a
circus yeah
and you get a hundred dollars now the US
the US won slap fight Championship that
one actually is like one run like a real
sport like they do drug testing they
have they have this thing where like if
you get knocked out three times you're
just out because they don't want CTE
like they I didn't even know there was
an American yeah slap fight Championship
is the American League oh my God it it
feels way more dangerous than like boxes
it is because you can't defend yourself
yeah
come on punch me in the face yeah right
I don't know it's terrifying it is the
thought of doing that oh my God you
cover like a lot of like little
underground sports like this though like
apart from slapping what are some of
your other favorites oh my God anyone
here a fan of backyard wrestling
please please explain this is this is as
American as it gets very Floridian no
this is this is very America okay
backyard wrestling it's it used to be
much bigger than it is now but it's
unauthorized unsanctioned wrestling
events
you just get like a bunch a lot of times
you get like some inbred people you get
a ring they get chairs
the same breeding makes them have no
pain just traditionally you'll get some
like actual wild people going crazy so
they get chairs and then eventually as
it ramped up in the early 2000s they
come came up with combat zone wrestling
czw and that's when they used like real
barbed wire real baseball bats and they
were just beating the [ __ ] out of each
other yeah and calling it wrestling they
jump off of roofs on top of each other
land on grass not even a ring that's
just like some old style [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah and there's one in particular they
were on YouTube I don't know if they are
anymore it's called p-o-r wrestling and
I'll never forget this stunt they wanted
to go so hard they had one of them get
hit by a moving like an actual speeding
vehicle so they of course it's wrestling
so they script everything so they're
like slapping each other yeah hits them
with like a toilet seat the guy's
stumbling and then a car comes in it's
going like 30. it's going at least 30.
bless it absolutely [ __ ] glasses he
flies over the car lands on the ground
and he's out I've never seen him again
he may have died I'm not sure never saw
him again
because it was hype it was going 30 at
The Spectators too because they had an
audience at The Spectators doesn't hit
me one and just blast that guy they were
so proud they did it again a month later
but this time through a motorhome so
they had two people wrestling on top of
like a motorhome trailer crashes the car
going 30 again through the motorhome at
The Spectators hits a tree it is so cool
they're making money they don't they
make zero dollars they're just
destroying they just love it yeah thrill
yep the love of the sport I thought the
DDT Japan was like crazy wrestling no
you guys have you guys have like a
backyard wrestling subsidiary I think
like something very similar all right I
don't know what it's called I filmed the
video with um DDT they're like typically
The Crazy Ones they want to do this
fights with
yeah I went to one of their shows it was
just so weird it was like it was a half
comedy show half wrestling yeah
acrobatics there's this whole bit with
these guys just got naked and shoved
their ass like going in like rotation
three of them in someone's face
and then smashed a plastic Ikea box on
him and it like fully shattered and it's
just like what is this like this that
sounds amazing
they legitimately have insane very good
talented wrestlers like the main show
but then they have like lower down they
have kind of like I don't know I mean
it's I don't even know what to describe
it like more show Show clown shows uh
but like one of the guys who I filmed
with he's he's a aew now and he's like
doing really well okay yeah yeah he's
got really funny yeah I think one of my
favorite videos I've seen recently which
is something I didn't know existed in
this day and age was it was a
documentary about the bare knuckle
boxing scene yeah yeah which one the
only reason I knew he exists was wrong
yeah the vice one did you see that one
yeah I saw that one yeah that's I
[ __ ] love that video it's like a debt
collector he's like a champion from
Liverpool yeah yeah he's from Newcastle
oh yeah and they were building up to
this like final event because there's
this bare knuckle boxing champion in
England right and then someone from
America like that's I think it was a
champion for America flew over to fight
him in England yeah a new Challenger
approaches right and so they build up
this massive Advantage follows like both
of their stories and you see the
American and he's like perfectly
chiseled you know he's exactly how what
you think a bare knuckle boxer should
look like right and then there's this
guy from [ __ ] Newcastle right who's
got like this [ __ ] massive beer like
drinking and eating like yeah
he was like drink you know he has like a
proper beer belly he's drunk most of the
time and so we will get to like the day
of the fights and the the Americans uh
the American is there on time ready to
fight and the guy from Newcastle is like
two hours late or something because he's
like he's he's been he's been drinking
he's been drinking my before and then he
shows up in this taxi [ __ ] drunk out
of his mind stumbling into the ring and
he [ __ ] wins this fight
it's one of the most British things I've
ever seen in my life it literally it
literally felt like a guy Richie movie
oh my God if you haven't watched that
video please watch it it's one of my
favorite videos I've watched recently
it's a vice documentary on it I think
it's the voice of Norman's wild bro yeah
it's up north now what are they doing
Florida that's one thing I wanted to ask
actually like how do you like stumble
upon these like kind of very like weird
underground like Niche you just get a
lot of people's messages yeah usually
people tell me about something silly
going on like telephone booth boxing is
Big right now okay hold on what is that
it's so it's a Russian sport I believe
they get two guys going to a telephone
booth and they just start boxing
specifically men let's just find 900
different ways to fight each other yeah
it's cool too like they don't hold back
back yeah they go [ __ ] wild in that
telephone booth and then people like
tweeted me like oh this looks like
something Charlie would like and then
I'll check it out yeah you're right
basically yeah what else any other weird
[ __ ] that you like I'm sure there's some
other [ __ ] up [ __ ] I found so many
weird communities there's this isn't a
community it's one guy but there's a guy
whose entire channel is built around
sitting on things wearing tight pants so
he sits on like hot lunches and birthday
cakes oh I remember I've seen this guy
it's [ __ ] weird it is he just like he
doesn't even do anything sexually sits
on it and then maybe they like moves a
little bit of the cake one time yeah
yeah okay is it like for review purposes
no no it's like silent right yeah I
think it's got to be a fetish but he
doesn't even do anything sexual he just
like sits on food I don't know he sits
on an orange in one of them
I'm interested
is that really a community but I mean
he's kind of cool
he's making the community man he's
building it I like to imagine that
there's like a secretly rented Community
for this bad guy I don't like the way
that he sat on that orange yeah I really
wish he changed the angle of that yeah
so did you go did you grow up in Florida
with us I've been here my whole life
yeah so as someone who is outside the US
you know we hear about Florida basically
through the internet yeah is it as crazy
as the internet portrays it as I I've
always wanted to know it's hard to say
like I definitely know of like really
Florida weird [ __ ] like even here in
Tampa and I mentioned this guy a lot he
used to be called the Ebor shoe licker
there's a place there's a place in Tampa
well
South from here called ibor and there's
a guy there who built himself up like a
big reputation for licking people's
shoes on the street so the guy just told
money no for fun so he hangs out he's
just on the street okay and if you walk
by him he'll ask if he can lick your
shoe and you expect like I imagine you
guys are picturing he like licks the top
of your shoe or something yeah he looks
the bottom of your shoe from bottom to
top in like one Fell Swoop what does he
get out of it he just likes it I don't
know I don't know he just likes it and
that's like a Florida staple well that's
a Tampa state
yeah there's one Chelsea new as well the
senator he in Ebor as well there's a
place called The Castle right and the
guy this his name was the senator he
would go there he'd go in like a g
string but he'd always pop Viagra so
he'd go like chubbed to this club to
dance and get wild and wacky
people rock on I feel like it's like a
different place yeah yeah like there are
those things that exist here but I on a
normal daily basis don't see too much
Florida [ __ ] you know because obviously
you like I said you've been in Florida
your whole life did you see a
progression where he got more weird over
the years or is it always kind of been
kind of odd to me it's always just less
documented yeah I think just less
documented I think because Florida has
like very open law where it's like
anyone who gets arrested it's all public
you can come check it out they have
videos usually so it's awesome
hey you see the new batch
come look at all the wild [ __ ] happening
in Florida guys here at this week's
Florida
new arrests just drop check it out
that's crazy I mean I guess that's where
the whole way forward man thing started
right 100 it's weird
um I know in where I'm where I was born
and raised there's a weird public roster
of all the criminals and when they
commit them they'll have the mug shot
I'm like this is what this guy did
really and like in like very not like
plain language and really like
opinionated language bizarre yeah yeah
it's yeah it's weird
stuff because you're from were you from
a small town you're like oh nothing bad
happens and then you you read this
you're like oh bad stuff happens yeah
okay yeah I definitely just didn't know
is weird